It will come home to roost.
I mean,
here's what's going to happen is Facebook
and youtube are going to fall prey to
their own standards because if their
standard is that you're responsible for
your followers or I'm responsible for
my followers or Jordan or anybody else's
responsible for all the people
who view their stuff. Okay,
then why isn't Facebook responsible for
all the people posting on its platform?
If they are right,
if Facebook becomes responsible for
all the people posting on his platform,
they'll be bankrupt in a week.
They've got a problem.
They really do because they have to
decide whether they are a platform or
whether they are a do gooder
publication. Yeah, I run,
I run a a publication daily wire.
It's openly conservative.
We make no bones about that and we are
responsible for the content that appears
on our platform and if we say something
to flammatory, we will be sued.
If we say something that is false,
then we will be sued.
Presumably if you post something falls
on Facebook, Facebook doesn't get sued,
but now Facebook has deemed itself the
morality police and they'll band people
they don't like and we'll decide what
editorially ought to be elevated and what
ought not to be elevated.
Does that sound more like
the phone company to you or
does that sound more like
my website where I decide what gets
published and what doesn't? Right.
Cause Facebook's case for
exemption from these laws is,
well we're like the phone company, right?
When you're on the phone with somebody,
if that person says something criminal
at t and t isn't responsible for the
person saying something
criminal or terrible, it's
just the phone company, right?
But Facebook isn't doing that.
Facebook is,
is jumping into the middle of
conversations and then saying,
well we don't really like
this conversation so we're
just going to kind of shut
it down. Not because of legal threat,
but because we just don't like it.
So are they actually doing that?
Like say if you
put a post up on Facebook and they
don't like the way you worded things or
describe things where they actually
shut down your post, what will they,
so they've done it in the
past to some conservative.
Publix is pretty controversial because
they're not transparent at all. Right.
I can tell you that at the beginning of
2018 we lost about 35% of our traffic
because Facebook started cracking
down on mostly conservative sites.
They said that it was kind
of new sites generally,
but that's not what the statistics showed.
They're doing it more often with things
that we all sort of agree are bad. Right?
We all agree white supremacy is bad.
White nationalism is bad.
Now they say they're going
to censor that stuff,
but here's where I'm uncomfortable.
I think that that stuff is awful and evil
and those people are, the ones are the,
they're the reason I
have personal security,
but once you get into the business of
Facebook gets to decide which speech is
good and which speech is bad. They're
an editor. Yeah, they're an editor.
Even if I agree with their assessment
of what stuff is good and what is bad,
I am not comfortable with them in the
driver's seat there and if they are going
to be in the driver's seat than they
should be held liable for all the stuff
that's on their platform. I
mean, why isn't the Twitter,
Twitter, same thing, right?
Why is it that Louis Farrakhan is still
on that platform but Alex Jones is not
like, I don't like Alex Jones
is material or I been very,
very critical of Alex Jones.
I didn't think you should get banned
from Twitter unless he actually violated
the law in, unless he was
responsible for a violent threat,
unless he was defamatory or
something like that. They're
definitely going down this road
of being the moral arbitrators.
They're, they're the ones who get to
decide what the conversations are and,
and that's an insane responsibility.
The responsibility of getting to dictate
what should and should not be discussed
and to have it to be a handful of people
and have these people almost almost
exclusively live in the Pacific Norton,
you know, north of San Francisco.
That whole tech community.
I mean it's all tech liberals who really,
if you're around those people,
they live in this really strange Uber
wealthy bubble of super genius spectrum
people who are coders and
super capitalists and people
that are raising money
all over the place and
designing technology and they
have an ideology and it's
not necessarily a bad one, just just
being honest and upfront about what it is.
It's this incredibly progressive, which
is very unusual for big business, right?
For big business to be just openly,
transparently progressive and pushing
social justice. It's very unusual.
Well, I think that there is a sort of
misunderstanding of when we say what big
business is,
what big businesses.
So I think that there's a wide variety
of owners of businesses and how they
think about politics obviously. Yeah.
Bill Gates is a progressive guy.
Warren Buffet's a progressive guy.
They are now, if it was bill gates,
supplies of his whole life. He's
ruthless with Microsoft. Well,
so I think that there
are a lot of listening.
I think that that the vast majority,
I think mark Zuckerberg is ruthless
with Facebook and use progressive.
I think Jack Dorsey is as ruthless as
the next guy when it comes to profit.
I mean, he's still gotta be answerable
to the shareholders. So I think,
I think a lot of the
progressivism is sort of a,
a way to excuse your own in your own
involvement in the capitalist market.
Facebook took off. Don't be evil. Like
that was their thing. Don't be evil.
They decided to remove that Google, right?
I say Facebook, I'm sorry Google. Yeah.
Yeah. When Google did that, I met Google.
Just funny. When you think something,
but you're saying another thing.
Um, when they did that, it's like,
why would you ever take off?
Don't be evil
like cheap that, but here's
my thing. Here's my thing.
I think that if our tech companies were
honest, they should take that stuff off.
Like stop pretending you're do Gooding,
you're not doing good and you're providing
a platform and maybe the platform is
the good mm. Right. In
a capitalist economy,
the product that you provide is the good,
I don't need additional good to
come from your product, right.
If you want to provide me a
solid morning drink, right?
I don't need your politics. Along
with that, I just need to drink. Well,
if I want a social media company,
I don't give two craps about what
Mark Zuckerberg thinks about politics.
Dude hasn't studied it. I don't
care at all. What Jack Dorsey,
who vacations in Malaysia and gets
bitten by a million mosquitoes while
meditating has to say
about the nature of life.
Like why do I care about Jack Dorsey's
political view? He has provided me a good,
the good is this basic chat
room where I'm consuming news.
How about that would just be enough,
but it's not enough for a lot
of these folks. It's, it's the,
the kind of Hooli from Silicon Valley.
We're going to pretend that we're here
to do good and it's not enough just to
acknowledge that maybe the thing
that you provided is the good,
like Bill Gates has done more good with
Microsoft and then has done with any of
the charities.
He's given a lot of money to charity,
but Microsoft has provided legitimately
a hundreds of thousands of jobs and
created enormously productive lines of
business and made enormous profit for a
lot of people. A lot of people have
stock in Microsoft as a general,
as a basic factual thing.
He has done more good doing that.
Then giving tens of millions of
dollars to, to various outside causes.
So it feels like a lot of the
progressivism in, in corporate halls, in,
in Silicon Valley is bifurcated mentally.
It's like people have, they're like,
dolphins is one side of the
brain on at a time. Here's my,
here's my capitalist side where
I got and make money and profit.
And then here's my other side where I
show people what a great person I am by
proclaiming that I'm for Bernie Sanders.
Well,
parking my money off shore to make sure
that they're, it's shielded from the,
from the tax man.
Yeah. Well that's a good assessment. Um,
what I'm saying is that
the don't be evil thing.
Like one of the things
that I thought was a,
what if that was like a legal
decision was me being cynical,
that they were pulled into some
sort of an office and said, um,
if we say don't be evil and you
take someone off the platform,
you're accusing them of evil.
That's it. I mean that we should slow that
down. Maybe, I mean again, this, this,
this self assessment of you are the
moral police I find really troubling and
it's so funny. I'm the, I'm the suppose
in more or less, right? Right. I'm,
I'm the religious guy. I'm
in the Orthodox Jew, right?
I talk about social standards and how
people should behave in their personal
life,
but when it comes to government and when
it comes to me imposing my views on you,
I am way less of a top down tyrant than
any of the people in Silicon Valley.
I am not here to tell you that you are
not allowed to be on a platform because
we disagree. It's one thing if
you're threatening violence,
which is an actual violation of law,
but this crap where people like me because
I believe in the social fabric built
on certain Judeo Christian values,
but I'm not forcing you to
be part of that and I'm not,
I don't think the government should
compel you to be a part of that or I'm the
tyrant,
but the person who sits at the top of
Twitter or Facebook who is saying that
they get to police what you see and
they're going to nudge you in the right
direction, nudge you in the right
direction without your consent,
without them even telling them what
you're doing right there. They're just,
they're going to push you a little bit
because they know better than you and
they can sort of massage you into better
views if we control your channels of
information. This is something the
Obama administration was very fond of.
There's a scholar named Cass Sunstein
as a legal scholar and he wrote a book
called nudge. He was very famous. It was,
it was used as sort of a handbook during
the Obama administration and the idea
was,
well,
if we can just use a non forcible means
to sort of nudge people in a particular
direction without them even
knowing they're being nudged,
then shouldn't we do that? And I think,
no, you shouldn't. You shouldn't.
Because transparency is the only way I
can tell what kind of bullshit you're
trying to sell me. Well, not yet.
Just that like you're, you're
closing down even conversation. If,
if, as soon as you try to
silence this other voice, if you,
if you believe one thing and another
person believes a different thing,
you should probably talk about it.
And the way,
the way that I know for sure there's
something wrong with your argument is if
what you're to do is you're sneakily
trying to silence these voices. And again,
as long as we're not talking
about threats of violence,
and as long as we're not talking
about harassment or doxing,
we're just talking about conversation.
You're just talking about people
with differing points of view.
If you want to silence
differing points of view,
I have to wonder about your intent.
I have to wonder about whether you're
going into this conversation with good
faith.
I have to wonder whether you've really
objectively assessed whether or not you,
your argument does hold up against
scrutiny because this is also part of the
problem.
And when you're in an echo chamber,
you often don't formulate
these arguments very well.
Like when you confront people about
certain bias beliefs that they have,
and you have an opposing belief,
if they're part of a bubble,
like sometimes they might not have even
ever considered some of the things you
have to say. And I've seen that
with some of your videos. Yeah.